[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter
dementors and of course souls more
specifically
we're going to be discussing a popular
fan theory which suggests that dementors
are perhaps
more drawn to harry than anyone else now
harry's had his fair share of run-ins
with dementors that's for sure
but what i want to look at today is
whether or not his copious run-ins with
dementors
was the result of sheer dumb misfortune
or whether they were constantly drawn to
harry for another reason
dementors are cloaked creatures that are
three meters tall with
dark gray scabby skin dementors are foul
creatures that represent unhappiness and
despair they are commonly known as the
guards of azkaban prison
responsible for ensuring that all the
darkest witches and wizards inside
do not escape dementors were originally
created by jk rowling
as a way of representing depression
rowling having
experienced depression herself wanted to
create a creature that personified all
the negative aspects of depression
dementors are among the founders
creatures that walk this earth
they invest the darkest filthiest places
they glory
in decay and despair they drain peace
hope and happiness out of the air around
them
even muckles feel their presence though
they can't see them get too near a
dementor and every good feeling
every happy memory will be sucked out of
you if it can
the dementor will feed on you long
enough to reduce you to something like
itself
soulless and evil you'll be left with
nothing the worst experiences
of your life when dementors attack
people they use what is called the
dementor's kiss
which is effectively the act of sucking
out that person's soul
being kissed by dementor is a fate
arguably worse than death
so if their main motivation is to suck
out more souls
then why should they be particularly
drawn to harry remus lupin
always expressed that it was the horrors
of harry's past that drew them closer to
him
but i don't think that's necessarily the
case today
i want to discuss a different theory on
wednesday october 31st
voldemort traveled to the town of
godric's hollow where the potter family
lived
it was here that voldemort in an attempt
to murder harry
ended up murdering james and lily he had
a very specific goal
and that was to kill harry when the time
came and voldemort finally pointed his
wondered harry he let out one last avada
kadavra
with the intention of killing the boy to
ensure the prophecy wouldn't come true
however the loving sacrifice that lily
had put in place
ensured that harry was protected which
meant that voldemort's killing curse
came firing right back at him what
voldemort essentially did on this day
was turn harry into a horcrux you see
when voldemort tried to kill harry
the curse rebounded which split
voldemort's soul but because voldemort's
body was gone
the victim of his own curse he could no
longer encase the soul fragment to
complete
the horcrux formation part of horcrack's
creation involves an encasing spell
which actually puts the soul outside of
the body into a physical object
because voldemort's soul was left
without any attachment
it latched itself to harry for this
reason harry contained voldemort's soul
fragment
but was never possessed by it however my
theory regarding harry and dementors is
this
the dementors were attracted to the
extra soul that harry carried with him
unwillingly harry went about his life
with an extra soul
strapped to him and i think that this
made him a target to dementors
a sort of two for the price of one to a
dementor
harry was the ultimate treat and that's
it for this video
what do you guys think is this theory
viable let me know
in the comment section below until next
time
remember to the well-organized mind
death
is but the next great adventure
you